y yo que levanto a hablar de revista de
prensa ya está conmigo lista en el
estudio rosa pérez más euros a ya
estamos a miércoles mitad de esta semana
vía encargada información con todo lo
que está pasando entre rusia y ucrania y
precisamente por ahí vamos a enfocar y
vamos a abrir esta revista de prensa
con la crisis de ucrania na pero lo
hacemos queriendo abordarlo desde un
punto de vista gráfico rosa empezamos
con un poco de humor porque incluso en
los momentos más críticos sirve para
explicar muchas cosas en pocas palabras
veamos la viñeta entonces de liberación
de gharyan y de times para relajarnos un
poco pues buenos días raúl sí a veces
pues hay que reír por no llorar no
empezamos sabiendo el dibujo de coco en
liberación en este medio francés en que
vemos al presidente ruso evolucionando
hacia una tanque de guerra no una
metáfora de este acercamiento pues del
conflicto a gran escala seguimos luego
con el humor británico en el medio de
the times de peter brooks aquí lo
tenemos y vemos al primer ministro del
reino unido- boris johnson vociferando
con él
de ucrania en la mano diciendo quiere
romper el derecho internacional se rodea
de modding de salud que sería como
perros que asienten lo que hemos como
querido traducir por vasallos
incondicionales no sé si podemos volver
a la caricatura anterior pero en resumen
de decía no conoce lo que es la verdad
siempre está mintiendo ese es mi trabajo
un poco en relación a la impunidad con
la que ha subido boris johnson de todo
el tema del partido y para terminar con
estas caricaturas vemos aquí la deben
jennings en the gardian vemos esta
imagen del presidente ruso con el torso
nudo no es fruto de la imaginación de la
caricaturista estas imágenes las gacelas
los vemos y efectivamente a lomo de un
caballo y está haciendo aquí un juego de
palabras de palabras homófonas no éstas
que suenan igual pero tienen
significados distintos entre peace paz y
peace pedazos no porque recordemos que
cuando vladimir putin anunció que iba a
mandar las tropas
este de ucrania dijo que era para un
misiones de mantener la paz pero aquí el
dibujante lo cita como he venido aquí
solamente a quedarme con un pedazo y
para que prestan muy buenas rosas estas
elecciones de estas caricaturas en torno
a todo este serio conflicto pero pues
nosotros le damos aquí un lado humor
para distensionar nos un poco pero
seguimos con elementos gráficos
fijémonos ahora en las portadas impresas
del mismo liberación de francia y de
metro británico efectivamente porque así
como indicaba la caricatura de hoy de
liberación en la misma línea va a su
portada no ucrania se prepara para la
guerra pues después de las últimas
medidas que hemos ido comentando y que
vamos siguiendo aquí en los noticieros y
por otro lado tenemos el metro este
tabloide británico sabemos que los
tabloides británicos siempre son muy
ocurrentes a la hora de titular y aquí
dice agarremos lo por los rublos los la
moneda rusa en relación pues a las
sanciones que están llevando a cabo eeuu
la unión europea reino unido contra
rusia así es rosa cambiamos ahora de
tema y vamos con otra grave cuestión que
como lo titula el 'new york times' son
los incendios forestales de gran
magnitud que pueden aumentar más de un
50% para finales de siglo es un artículo
de reimond sound efectivamente este
artículo hace referencia al primer
estudio que ha realizado naciones unidas
en relación al riesgo de grandes
incendios forestales en todo el mundo y
esto después de que en los últimos años
se acentuará la gravedad de estos
incendios en zonas que no estaban
acostumbradas pues a sufrir este tipo de
daños naturales como por ejemplo rusia o
la india y tal y como señala este
artículo este comité de naciones unidas
indica que la sequía y el aumento del
calor y las repetidas pues olas de calor
pueden provocar que para finales de
siglo aumenten hasta un 57 por ciento
estos grandes incendios y aquí en el
artículo vemos distintas fotografías
devastadoras de lo que hemos ido viendo
en los últimos años pues en australia en
la india en sudáfrica en estados unidos
o en europa y precisamente en este
sentido vemos un artículo de la nación
de argentina en relación a los incendios
de corrientes y rápidamente ariel torres
el periodista comenta la anomalía
climática
se instaló allí no llovía en pleno
verano era cuestión de sumar dos más dos
y es que precisamente una de las cosas
que recalca este informe es que los
gobiernos alrededor del mundo deben
ampliar sus medidas de prevención y de
actuación frente a estos grandes
incendios o si no pues las situaciones
van a ser cada vez más devastadoras hay
que actuar ya en torno a lo que está
pasando con nuestro planeta y cambio
climático como estamos destruyendo
nuestra propia casa rosa muchísimas
gracias nos vemos mañana con más de
revista de prensa pasamos ahora a
saludar a nuestro primer invitado al día